I'm Christine Boinett.
I am a post-doc working in pathogen genomics at the
Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute in
Cambridge. My work involves looking at bacteria
in particular ones that are a problem in
hospitals because they're resistant to
so many antibiotics that doctors commonly use.
I'm using a combination of lab work
DNA sequencing and computational work to
understand how bacteria become resistant
to antibiotics.
I want to understand if resistance is
something they acquire
or if it's just naturally there within
them. While half my time is more informatics based
the other half is spent in the lab.
In the lab I grow up bacteria on agar plates and then
see how they respond to different antibiotics
While some bugs will be killed by the antibiotics
others will be resistant and these are the
ones that i'm interested in.
I like the hands-on element of working in the
lab -
setting up the experiments and then
coming back the next day and discovering the results.
When I find the bugs that are resistant
to antibiotics, I isolate their DNA
I then get this DNA sequenced
Back on my computer, I then compare
this DNA sequence to a database of genes
known to be involved in antibiotic
resistance.
I can then see if any of these
resistance genes are in my sample.
More and more I'm enjoying the computational side of my research
because it enables me to
really pinpoint the mechanisms of
antibiotic resistance.
I always enjoyed science in school but
really got fascinated about
drug resistance when I was doing my degree.
During my degree I spent a year in
industry looking at drug resistance in HIV.
Understanding how one mutation can cause
resistance to a whole class of anti-virals
was really intriguing to me.
I've studied the mechanisms of drug resistance
in bacteria ever since
first for my PhD and now here at the Sanger Institute.
I really enjoy working in research
I get to collaborate with lots of very
accomplished scientists
and they challenge me every day, to me that's how you really grow as a scientist.
Drug resistance is fascinating to me, I just want to find out
more about how it develops and how we might overcome it.
I love what I do!